[Music]
what's going on guys
the snap the ramifications and
repercussions of it were felt around the
universe from Wakanda to Asgard but what
about picking up the pieces right after
the snap five years later what does it
mean to us psychologically legally
politically we're about to do a deep
dive and unpack all of that right now
and we've got a panel of experts to do
it with first we have our political
expert she worked on Capitol Hill in
Washington DC for ten years she's served
as a consultant on the awesome comedy
veep and she has a master's in public
policy she also can be heard on her
upcoming podcast spin proof
Jennifer hole sir Jennifer thank you so
much for being here the pleasure to be
here I think next we have our psychology
expert she has a PhD in clinical
psychology
she works for UCLA oh this is really
cool she has a podcast on the psychology
of Batman called the Arkham sessions and
she serves as a consultant for WB drea
litt Amenti thanks for having me
and finally our legal expert he was a
lawyer in New York City for ten years a
legal blogger and he's a host on his
show tempting fate on twitch.tv slash
saving throw Rick bud first off let me
ask this do you guys see Avengers
endgame yes many times
thank God otherwise we've made a
colossal error okay so I'm excited to
dive into this stuff
drea I'm actually going to start with
you um what are some of the
psychological effects of thinking let's
say I think my wife is gone and then all
of a sudden she shows back up five years
later what's that going to do to my head
it's such a tremendous recovery process
right so in thinking of just how many
people disappeared it's the initial loss
and then there may be one or two billion
more people who died from the
catastrophic
like accidents and not having doctors
not having first responders because it's
not just the people who were lost it is
all of the folks who can help during the
recovery half of those people have been
lost - you know certainly in the five
years that pass we see more destruction
psychologically amongst the people who
have survived and then for the folks
that come back there is that sense of
absolute confusion
perhaps disillusionment perhaps even the
need to recover from the years that you
know their family members and friends
have aged sometime then they need to
reconcile with not having aged yeah so a
lot to unpack and deal with there let's
say that I've reconciled with it
and I'm in a support group I meet
someone who lost her husband I lost my
wife we get married and then our
significant others come back legally are
we still married are the marriages
dissolved what about my new marriage
Rick help me out here well you know it's
it's there in the marriage vows till
death do us part and those people who
disappeared in the snap were not missing
they were dead half the world saw the
other half of the world literally turned
to dust before their eyes it's not a
case of you know what if that person's
still out there so yeah your marriage
ended at death you know your will was
probably executed so that new family
probably now has your property and your
money and the ripple effects of of that
marriage being dissolved will just go
all the way through everyone's lives
okay let's say but I just came back I
want my stuff back
I want my house I want my collection of
rare coins fit figurines if the person
who owns them now doesn't want to give
you them back you're probably out of
luck but barring some sort of political
act or some sort of legislation that
somehow massively
returns property to the returners right
so yet so it's shift gears there so is
there any precedent as far as
legislation to immediately cover that
sort of thing honestly the closest thing
I have in terms of dealing with some of
these issues yeah would be the end of
slavery you have a big population who
came in with no possessions with nothing
and then they have to start over
initially there'll be so much sympathy
for this population why do something for
them and then they start to become the
refugees half the population will be
unemployed like immediately and so yeah
food stamps maybe maybe wait where are
you putting them on them but yeah if you
don't get in their wealth back I mean
it's one thing somebody might give you
your figurines back well what are the
banks gonna give you your money back
you know generations later you see the
people still struggling yeah it's like
you were like you arrived back so you're
saying if you arrived back you're
basically like a refugee you come back
with nothing
exactly unless somebody you know again
if your wife and kids or we've moved on
if people want to help you and take care
of you but it's kind of like how long do
you take care of your ex-wife that's a
good question I mean I'm just the guilt
lasts after the snap
that's when political structures fail I
mean I mean like it could crumble I mean
that's when you could see an
authoritarian step in and say look cuz
there's fear I mean when this happened
you're not sure it's not gonna happen
again ever Matt am I at risk now I mean
you have all the psychological effects
but um and it's interesting in the
Marvel Universe if this happened in our
current universe and there weren't
superheroes and something like this
there's a snap that's when you see an
authoritarian titled leader come in and
say look you guys like I can keep you
safe how would it affect someone to just
have the rug of life pulled out from
under them knowing that a jacked purple
dude and snap his finger and wipe out
half of us like well yeah a huge loss of
personhood along with the losses that we
were just talking about so I think
initially we'd have the celebration of
like we're finally all united we're back
we're okay
you know no one has the long term
visible injuries but in a lot of ways we
have to think about those invisible
injury
and we saw it in the film a little bit
before the folks returned right there
were some therapy or sort of grief
sessions that folks were participating
in we're gonna see similar need to have
support and some level of talking about
what happened let's say before the snap
I loaned my friend I just loaned him
$5,000 because he wanted to start a food
truck okay then I get snapped away he's
you know driving around his food truck I
come back
does he still owe me that $5,000 yeah
that's a tough one I guess it would
depend on the circumstances the loans
are made out of but made under but the
truth is is that you loaned your friend
$5,000 and then you disappeared right so
if that money was owed to you your heirs
or whoever controlled your estate might
have acted to recoup that money or part
of it after you were dead as part of
settling your estate okay that claim is
possibly relinquished already in which
case you're gonna come back and find
whoever it was that was in charge of
your estate has liquidated your assets
cashed in your debts settled you know
what you owed yourself to other people
okay let me ask you this someone owes me
$5,000 I die do they owe it to my heirs
probably what happens then this is a
tough one because there are precedents
for people who have faked their own
death or people who were alive as
prisoners of war when nobody knew there
is no precedent for what happens if you
are actually physically dead and then
resurrecting unless there's something
called imminent peril where it's like if
you were on a plane and that plane
crashed into the side of a mountain and
now they can't find your body the court
will say look given the imminent peril
he was in on a plane that crashed into a
mountain we can assume he's dead and
they chopped that way down yeah so I
think that happened in castaway with Tom
Hanks he was declared dead
these people I'll be legally dead they
wouldn't have social security numbers
anymore they yeah I mean you even see a
little evidence for this in the movie
when Scott Lang goes and sees his name
on the
memorial to the dead in the film even
though he was not out of the people
snapped away but the movie seems to
imply given that Scott was treated as
someone snapped away that there was some
kind of act that just blanked it
declared everyone should not put out the
font on that monument was awfully large
half the population I 150 million us
like it was like they could have been a
little more efficient with the fog yeah
let me ask you this what if what if
there's a woman who's who's like husband
is a jerk her boss is an a-hole and
and there's like you know she's got a
bully from high school as well and they
all get snapped away and she's like this
snap is the best thing that ever
happened to me then they all come back
what's that psychology well certainly
for some people experiencing joy or some
some kind of relief from the SAB could
happen right and so that might be
realistic but upon those perpetrators
returning I think that's unfortunate for
her I mean that's she had several years
to reconcile that and perhaps even move
along and create very positive
fulfilling relationships and then and
what about having to fake being upset
about this actually I was so upset and
meanwhile you're actually just like yeah
peace out he's will was executed and now
she's got all of his stuff speaking of
support systems let's talk about the
international support system in a crisis
like this where half of everything goes
how would the international community
work together and whatever is there any
precedent it would actually be a massive
humanitarian crisis I think in a lot of
other countries and so they would need a
lot more help so while we were trying to
look for ways to help our 50% unemployed
here in the country they'd be wanting us
to then give them money and since I step
in
you might there you might need
peacekeepers you might know like
warlords could kind of come up in some
of these areas you could see I mean it
would it would put a like just global
turmoil a massive scale
you have to sort out who's in charge of
watch because sitting like Black Panther
was gone for five years that somebody
else has been the monarch of Wakanda he
now shows up again how Wakanda decides
do we keep the guy who's with the keep
who ever has been King for five years or
or Queen for five years or does tajalli
get his kingdom back before Wakanda can
go out and start helping the world or
helping anybody yeah Avengers should not
retire the new snap uh I think they'll
have to go put peace you know right help
subtle massive works if you're in the
foes we know there's been a little bit
of a changing of the guard yeah yeah
well it's good changing i-i've just
saying like there's this there's
probably probably need on all hands on
deck for a couple of years to get you
know nuclear weapons secured to get you
know warlords taken care of to make sure
food gets distributed that kind of thing
somebody's gonna put Hawkeye on trial
he's been going around murdering without
got any Burger machines
he's only been killing bad guys he shows
one of many different responses yes
swallowing trauma so actually found his
story to be quite fascinating because we
do see some folks Captain America
Black Widow there's there's some level
of healthy functioning among the
original six some survivor's guilt but
certainly they're moving forward and
then you have other folks who are
dealing with the trauma and such
destructive self-destructive and and
other destructive ways and I thought
that what they his pathway I thought was
particularly interesting and not
unrealistic actually legally what would
happen if you have massive assets like
let's say Jeff Bezos
or Warren Buffett and you're snapped
away and then you come back oh you're
gonna be very sad just like anybody else
you're dead and I'm sure Jeff Bezos has
a will and that will gives his company
I'm sure or his shares of his company to
his children his wife whoever survived
the snap I have no recourse well this is
where Thanos was right death is the
great leveler of everybody not even
even Warren Buffett okay what happened
to Jimmy Buffett would he be able to go
get his lost Shay currents of salt well
she has beloved fans everywhere he would
take care of him I mean yes they carry
hands Parrotheads would help them out
I'm just saying it all comes down to how
you know much people like you and your a
lot good lesson to take out of that you
mentioned kids drea I want to ask you
how do I explain the snap to a child I
depends on the age of the child right so
vulnerable age like they don't even know
death yet so it's thinking of the tragic
events that we've had that are just as
traumatic loss of lives total
destruction 9/11 comes to mind we do
have to be thoughtful about how we
communicate to to our younger citizens
and especially to young children so
there are different levels of handling
that for very young children you have to
be straightforward and speak in a very
clear manner about what is actually lost
and so that could be just a matter of
you know certainly not the details about
the snap but the benefit of the snap is
that it was very mysterious to begin
with the randomness of the snap makes it
a little easier to describe because we
had no way of predicting this so it's
basically gonna be super hard to explain
to kids
okay so let's we're picking up the
pieces everyone just came back how do we
best explain to them what has happened
in the interim while they were gone do
we make some sort of Ken Burns
documentary is one oh yeah snap yeah or
maybe you get professor Hulk to host
some sort of Bill Nye style show I would
watch that oh I watch the hello
like posit this question to everybody
so obviously Thanos took away our loved
ones took away our friends massive
villain could you see though a pro
Thanos contingent out there what kind of
person would get behind
sano psyche maybe then psychologically
then actually see Steve Rogers in the
movie rationalize hey the water is
cleaner than it's ever and if that's
Captain America you got to imagine
regular people trying to rationalize
what happened might come around to the
idea that hey this was not such a bad
thing what Tony Stark had a kid who he
didn't want to give up every turn every
person who rationalizes some sort of
you're sounding a little bit pro fan of
my man well I'm just getting in the
spirit of the movie sorry I mean is it
definitely when we're in situations
where it is so random where you have no
control where you want it you want an
explanation and that's when you start
turning to you know maybe maybe if we
pray to Thanos he won't do it again now
that maybe if we you know Jennifer
that's fascinating do people start
worshipping Thanos as that was the
rapture and and then people are like
Avengers you're the Antichrist or
something for reversing the rapture yeah
we don't really live with uncertainty
well so psychologically we do begin to
build schemas ideas ways that we can
make sense of this and I logical sense
that there would be folks who would band
together and become understanding of the
situation would form their own theories
of the situation and then when a post
snap five years later the population
returns there would be that secondary
event that I think would cause a lot of
social and psychological destruction
adding on to the initial one yeah back
to mention it's like I guarantee you
they're gonna be people out there who
try and Sue the Avengers not-not-not
every jurisdiction protects good
Samaritans yeah take an active role in
trying to prevent an accident or a
tragedy and then you fail and somehow
make it worse or or you know exacerbate
the circumstances there are many
jurisdictions in which
you become liable and I mean in this
world you got to imagine there are
million lawyers being like oh yeah the
Avengers got deep pockets we're going
after that politicians saying no I mean
like the Avengers are the ones you
brought that us on they cause this like
he wouldn't come here if they hadn't
provoked him like so fascinating I have
so many more questions I feel like we we
should make a Ken Burns documentary
about about this subject do you guys
have any final thoughts anything you
wanted to share with us regarding the
snap I mean I would say realistically
speaking you know in real life the
number of people who have access to
lawyers and then the percentage of cases
that go to the courts are miniscule so
given that half the population of the
world would now have claims and legal
issues there is just no chance that any
legal system anywhere on earth would be
able to handle this and really all
everything will have to happen at the
political level overwhelmed yeah I I
would say that if anything endgame is a
lesson in trauma recovery that it is
possible for us to to be able to heal it
takes a long time but I think
psychologically speaking I have a little
bit more of an optimistic perspective
mm-hmm Jennifer I would say we should
start electing politicians who think
about the long run ahead and and or look
a little more like Tony Stark you know
at least morally and wanting make the
world a better place they say think
globally act locally think
intergalactically who do you want to be
representing you it's interesting just a
final thought George Washington back you
know First Continental Congress said
send us your best people Congress and I
you know we don't think of those terms
anymore and I think when we're facing an
event like this you want your best
people there who gonna be thinking long
term we're gonna be better I'm not hurt
yes best people right here today
Jennifer holes are drill at Amenti and
Rick bud thank you so much for
enlightening us and making us into the
post snap pre-snap universe do you have
any more questions that we didn't answer
do you have any answers that we ask
questions to let us know in the comment
section below I want to know your
thoughts on the PO
snap universe I want to thank you for
watching and once again I want to thank
my guests they were fantastic
hit me up on Twitter and Instagram at
Hal Rudnick and see you next time
bye-bye
[Music]